[Musique]
beaucoup d'eau avant
commençons d'abord par un des chiens
[Musique]
à
les mauvais temps les prix chutent
chaque film en fait les châtains tronçon
des couleurs particulières et poids
république ne plus prendre le bus de
ville et elle a les jambes une énorme
plaque sur la classe et son comité art
en ciel comme hambourg n'ont pas de
cette nouvelle tâche est facilitée venu
sonner chez l'autre
malgré ses pattes
à imola s'enraye
non
quand on y va on
d'y aller c'est pas d'effort autres sais
pas comment choisir déjà l'encré rouge
est arrivé de la peinture fluo sur la
gueule en cours d'année ajouté
eh bien il convient de se faire des
liens afin de les conditionner et
pouvoir repartir parce que c'est
techniquement et ça marche
[Musique]